le cinéma avec un film très attendu
soleil levant de philip kaufman une
histoire entre japonais et américains le
flic américain est joué par sean connery
qui justement à une particulière
attirance pour le japon nicole cornu
langlois l'a rencontré à londres à los
angeles
les points de friction et de tensions
entre japonais et américains sont
fréquents ils peuvent devenir explosif
lorsqu'il s'agit du meurtre d'une femme
pendant une conférence pour la lutte de
pouvoir il faut alors rappeler un
policier légendaire pour mener l'enquêté
john connor féru de culture japonaise
il a le visage de sean connery pour ce
look quasi monastique j'ai eu la
moustache tirés vers le bas et je me
suis laissé pousser les sourcils pour
pouvoir les remonter et avoir cette
expression de moine et vous avez dû
aussi apprendre le japonais chez des
gens comme ça on met les qualités croate
est ce juste les quelques mots que
j'avais à dire mais je ne parle pas très
bien c'est une langue extrêmement
difficile à chaponost une conception
différente du temps je pense que c'est
là le coeur du problème entre japonais
et américains vous ne pouvez plus vivre
sans être conscient de la puissance
japonaise
mais ce n'est pas vraiment le sujet du
film je pense que c'est très important
d'avoir de l'humour
en fait si vous n'en avez pas vous ne
pouvez rien accepté et de l'humour cet
écossais n'en manquent pas à la ville
comme à l'écran
m